[Music]
and not worth it news this one's
submitted by yang gang gang gang people
in Singapore are getting arrested for
buying airline boarding passes without
the intent to travel right what I heard
about this are they reselling the
tickets like Timmy shoes no no they're
just buying a boarding pass to visit the
airport what because the airport in
Shanghai is [ __ ] dope wait in
Singapore I heard the airport of
shanghai still do that see the airport
ching hai's dope - I'll just leave it in
I've been to the Singapore Airport I
will say gum is a little there oh
whatever
if you're on patreon you know where that
jokes coming from so they have put signs
in the Singapore Airport not Shanghai
saying it is an arrestable offence to
enter the transit area if you do not
intend to travel even if you have a
boarding pass that's how I fall there
they are they could just buy a boarding
pass and not even use it what are these
oh [ __ ] Wow it's cuz all these people
watch crazy rich Asians and [ __ ] they
want to probably go there I don't know I
finally watched crazy rich Asians
that's [ __ ] fallen though you just
know it's just like bada tickets to San
Diego in Vegas you just vided advanced
you're like it's $46 but I guess until
in the airport all day but from
Singapore it's gotta be in the hundreds
or thousands of dollars no but what
they're doing is though so some people
will purchase a boarding pass
enjoy the airport and then ask for a
refund
oh yeah it takes off so it's people
already in Singapore oh my god I would
definitely do that
yeah CEO like immediately we're already
pay if they're paying for and just be
like oh I'm just not gonna get on the
flight that's different because it's
like you know you you know you're that's
somebody else's time though but then
you're wasting your voice they're saying
that this recently this twenty
seven-year-old bought a ticket only like
the sole reason to buy this ticket was
to walk his wife to the gate and he had
no intention to disrespect
right I feel like you would do that's me
I do it just smack my wife on the answer
she gets on the plane I say that you
play the hard roll but you're [ __ ]
Eminem you got a you got a hard candy
sale on the inside I [ __ ] hard lovingly
no love for 30 do it so they say that 33
people have been arrested under the
legislation [ __ ] arrested Justin 2019
see your pores are poor yeah yeah it's
cuz they have a law that says if you're
not flying you cannot be in the airport
they got loose boarding pass policies
two guys over here with one sits within
24 hours of the flight you can't refund
it anymore
yeah yeah so for them the fact that they
could even refund it up of the gate yeah
up to the gate that's super lien yeah so
this Airport this new terminal opened
that it opened in April made headlines
around the world because of the 40 meter
waterfall which is the world's largest
indoor one that photo I showed you it's
beautiful
14,000 square meter canopy Park with a
suspension bridge Toto pari and maids to
be thank you topiary and mazes and one
of Asia's largest indoor gardens with
3,000 trees and 60,000 child why they
spend all this money on the air I don't
buy this fake Airport tick I would never
get a chance to see that I would have to
get to the airport 16 hours ahead of my
flight this would be ever enjoyed
[ __ ] Airport I'm doing it breaking
the [ __ ] law man I'm risking at all
no you wouldn't be breaking the law
because you're intending to fly it's the
time then I'll just slip and fall before
my flap like oh I can't fall I'll take
what you're gonna drag your ass dude
it's the [ __ ] Wonka Factory in there
it's crazy just see all that's me yeah
no I didn't see that part of it I was in
and out quick when will you know was it
this year no I was like four years ago
terminal just was a new terminal yeah
take a shower right yeah like I said I
never been in that [ __ ] I was like I was
like I was there it was cool but I
didn't see this I don't see the walk
there have you ever tried doing one of
these showers where it's like over the
head it feels nice like a sunflower
shower it's like a wall that's not
constantly warm for the show I don't
like it because by the time I hits my
body because I'm shorter it's already
cold who just wants to make another take
that long I did this I took a shower and
like that time for shower just one and
it was a really high feeling like how
high like high as the ceiling
um water doesn't become cold yeah what
and then I got cold by the time I hit
you yeah the [ __ ] maybe just doesn't get
that hot how do you know it doesn't get
hot oh it wasn't that hot yeah but I got
cold so like [ __ ] these showers don't
like it you don't like this showers just
because you had a cold shower
nobody likes a cold shower because those
my first and only experience with the
waterfall showers that tide again yeah I
didn't I thought you were gonna say that
that [ __ ] hurt cuz you're so small that
[ __ ] [ __ ] came and slapped you in the
face
no that's the only thing I didn't like
about it that the pressure wasn't strong
enough what it was two weeks I'm like
you [ __ ] took a shower in a mist you
like a hard water shower
what do you mean the water like [ __ ]
I like feeling pressure the left the
water you get it like an Asian spa yes
that's the best I like you gotta have
the hairs if you gotta adjustable here
you can find something that you like
with like if it's just one one I feel
like I mean what that's on the top
that's the waterfall that's your option
waterfall or not but like they also have
like because when I had he had the
waterfall over the top and then it also
had a hose coming from I mean I head
right here and then it had like a mid
body wash so yeah it was lovely yeah man
that was cheap myself no yes the ones
with the the [ __ ] what do you call it
the steam so you could you have the
steam on yeah
there's a shower yeah so you turn on the
steamer so then it's like so that you're
never cold like in the winter it's
perfect but it's only inside of the
shower door right the same isn't like in
the whole bathroom no no it's in the
shower so that I mean the shower is like
a walk-in like huge thing right so it's
like a steam room yeah then you could
turn on the [ __ ] water and you could
either have it cold or hot or whatever
and it's nice you should get a Vegas
suite okay we should do a shower podcast
I'm not rich enough to be here guys I'm
good but I'm not I'm not
you guys obviously doesn't even know
what [ __ ] bed he has he's like
sixteen bathroom camera discussion 48
bedrooms how can I keep count no we
don't we don't even this is what you do
you go to Vegas on a weekday and you get
normal prices for like balling that [ __ ]
this is true I've done that before yeah
yeah I pay like thirty nine dollars for
something at what is that one smells
really good with live win the cows are
really good on the inside like soon as
you walk in it's like I like the hot
abre common use of smell policy you just
like blow on it's just smells great I'm
not going in that store like it smells
like a cologne store yeah it smells
great though I hate that's much you hate
smell good I like alone you stink now oh
no I smell good Cologne I'm like what do
you wear to ensure that I wear deodorant
that's it this deodorant a soap that's
it yeah actually I shower every day
let's let's put this live to be do you
use a towel will you shout it's a very
personal question I will not answer give
me like a little hand towel
now on face out I'm not answering that
question if you use a loofah
that's very private it's not private man
I think that's common knowledge
that's invasive are you using your bare
hands are you using the object to clean
your bodies all right you want the truth
yes good you want the truth I use man
yeah I used to use this a sponge in a
loofah and I got lazy yeah I think your
use soap too but now I just use shampoo
MUFAs get dirty every 30 days that's
what was in your it's 30 or 45 days
because the bacteria in it never dies I
get the reason why it's a lot of yeah no
just like a plastic I'm keep your bodies
dirty but like let's say looks like a
black hey I'm Jackie here [ __ ] the
turtles right [ __ ] the turtles it's not
a [ __ ] can case you hate Turtles huh
sea turtles no no I went to I want to
white just to swim with the sea turtles
thank you very much like a hand towel
then that goes that lashes I use a hand
towel yeah you can walk okay that you
can watch that you can you watch loofahs
can you watch a loofah
no saving it man cuz that's a WoW that
Street will come out there to come
undone this is like girls right you see
all the holes that he can't wash that
yeah holy put it in a dishwasher
oh they're young gets water from every
direction nope thank you
I use the Asian we'll all right column
Asian cuz the ones that are like it
looks like yeah that's what I used to
but it's a really scrubbing that's it
yeah let's not go exfoliating thing oh I
just use my hands normally cuz I don't I
want to take a quick shower but then
what that being like I use it once a
month just to like I guess take the time
to really get off the top layer of
building I'm judging the [ __ ] out of you
guys are nasty rich people are we now
see are you sure
the towel are done today what are you
talking about do you exfoliate i sculpt
the heart that means how about that and
I'm proud yeah you don't use a coffee
scrub anything you did just I use an
apricot scrub okay I have a face wash
that I use once a month I feel like
you've seen it in the store you don't
really use it
bingo-bango you got it I won't say this
you're very good yeah you're very good
coffee scrubs are great because they
they exfoliate the open up the skin but
also the caffeine is good for your skin
you do it after you every body's good
for your skin far away wait for word but
sugars bad for your skin though just
kidding they have sugar scrubs yeah I'm
sure did you sugar me all this type of
stuff oh you know what it actually is
waking up a little bit alright shed it
up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]